bonjour david vous êtes à erevan la
capitale de l'arménie le premier
ministre qui a promis des législatives
anticipées est ce que ça va calmer les
ardeurs de l'opposition
eh bien ce n'est pas effectivement tout
à fait le cas en tout cas ici à erevan
est devant le parlement vous le voyez
aller et comment sont toujours derrière
moi et à l'opposition compte bien aller
au bout des choses 1 selon nos
informations et les réactions à chaud
qu'on a pu avoir hier soir ici devant le
parlement et bien l'opposition
refuserait la tenue de nouvelles
élections législatives anticipées
un seul but un seul but commun pour
l'opposition le départ de nikol
pashinian considéré comme un traître et
un ennemi de la nation depuis la défaite
un militaire dans le haut-karabakh on
l'a vu auparavant
elle est militant propage signal était
au rendez vous hier soir ils ont répondu
à l'appel de nicolas pas shinya la place
de la république à 18h30 heure locale
des milliers de partisans du premier
ministre arménien qui lui accorde encore
une fois leur confiance il nous explique
pourquoi on écoute
nous soutenons nikol pashinian
aujourd'hui parce que nous savons qu'il
est honnête il ne peut pas être un
traître
tous les gens qui étaient coupables de
la guerre je suis sûr qu'ils seront
bientôt en prison parce que nous croyons
pas chine jan nous croyons au
gouvernement et aujourd'hui nous sommes
ici pour protéger le pays des traîtres
[Musique]
nous croyons notre chef nous croyons en
notre premier ministre
nous avançons avec l'esprit nous ne nous
vendons pas pour 5000 drame
nous ne vendrons pas notre âme au diable
comme le font certaines personnes
personne ne devrait oser dire que nous
avons perdu la guerre et nous ne sommes
pas du côté offensif pour exiger sa
démission parole qui contraste
énormément avec les mots qu'on peut
entendre ici un devant le parlement et à
l'opposition comptent bien tenir son
rang ici devant le parlement arménien
afin de réclamer le départ de nikol
pashinian le programme aujourd'hui pas
de nouvelles mobilisations pro pas xian
a noté à cet après-midi en revanche ici
devant le parlement devrait se tenir une
nouvelle mobilisation afin de réclamer
le départ du premier ministre
à noter également que le conseil
national de sécurité de l'arménie a
approuvé la demande de nicole pas xian
concernant la révocation du chef d'état
major de l'armée à souvenez-vous le
président armen sarkissian avait refusé
cette demande est bien le conseil
national de sécurité
elle lui a demandé au président
d'approuver cette fameuse motion en tout
cas ce qu on peut noter également c'est
que les différentes mobilisations les
différents rassemblements qu'il y a eu
hier
eh bien il n'y a pas eu de tension
particulière ni d'affrontement entre pro
et anti un patch inial le soulèvement
populaire se veut pacifiste c'est en
tout cas le mot le mot d'ordre ici un
devant le parlement arménien et le mot
d'ordre est des partisans qu'il y a au
sein de détente un que vous pouvez voir
derrière moi alors reste à savoir
maintenant comment l'opposition va
s'organiser
gresset ce pas en avant en fait par
nikol pashinian dans quelles
dispositions il
ils vont pouvoir tenir leur rang de rang
ce parlement l'avenir nous dira en tout
cas on suivra avec attention ici depuis
erevan
merci beaucoup david pour toutes ces
précisions david khalifa en direct de
erevan